oh man - correct me if I'm wrong but you
guys you're obviously very funny in
person there's a lot of riffing joking
around on the set where you are trying
to add to the script and see if you can
get things onto the show that are your
creation and the writers and the
producers are trying to stop you from
doing that is that right yeah well I
mean the scripts are always like high
level stuff and we feel like we can you
know add to it I mean Zack has a great
riff that about tampons soaked in
alcohol grain alcohol yes which I don't
know did you raise your personal
preoccupation do you want to tell us do
you want to tell us a little bit about
they actually did written just never
actually made it into an episode but
where Jared develops an alter ego who is
a somewhat predatory guy and he talks
about how to get drunk he soaks a tampon
in grain alcohol and puts it inside and
put it inside himself yeah I did it's
called butt chugging yeah and it's a
real thing also some that you're chewing
a public-service I know guys are a
hip-hop dance yeah it's not cold but
chunky guys
get those tampons out of those butthole
even in the vaginas where they belong
hey save some lives here tonight
don't bite chug but you won't pass a
breathalyzer if you do okay weird
disclaimer we have saved some lives
yeah you know what I'm driving back to
LA so thanks mr. Richter are you okay
I'm fine
you